Last CPP con, there were several talks about AI, and there seemed to be more about in every conference. And in particular, several of the talks started out by saying, okay, I'm not going to address any non-technical concerns. We're just going to stick to the technicalities. And, you know, that's a very sort of privileged position to take, and I find myself unable to take that position. Man is a political animal, as Aristotle said. You cannot not, you know, inaction is a form of action. and I just sort of look around and I ask myself, is this doing the world any good?
在上一届CPP con上，有几场关于人工智能的演讲，而且似乎每个会议上关于这方面的演讲都更多了。特别是，有几场演讲一开场就说，好吧，我不会去谈任何非技术性的担忧。我们只专注于技术细节。你知道，这是一种非常具有特权地位的表态，而我发现自己无法采取那种立场。正如亚里士多德所说，人是政治动物。你不可能不表态，你知道，不作为也是一种行为。我只是环顾四周，然后问自己，这真的对世界有任何好处吗？
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 289, recorded on May 27, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we get an update on Ben's thoughts on AI, the first since August of 2025. I was talking to Jason a couple months ago at a meetup. Jason Turner for potentially, irregular listeners. Yes, but continue. And I was saying to him, like, we were talking about, like, how should we think about the effects of AI in this area, about the atrophy of skills or whatever. And he made an interesting analogy, which is that, you know, so to a first approximation,
欢迎来到ADSP播客，第289期，录制于2020年5月27日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是本，我们听取了本对人工智能最新看法的更新，这也是自2025年8以来的首次。几个月前我在一次聚会上和杰森交谈过。对于不太固定的听众来说，是杰森·特纳。是的，不过请继续。我对他说，我们在讨论，比方说，我们应该如何看待人工智能在该领域的影响，比如技能的退化等等。他提出了一个有趣的类比，那就是，对一个一阶近似而言，
today, one cannot buy good quality furniture, certainly not in a way that one could buy it a hundred years ago, right? The reason is simply that nobody is making that kind of quality furniture anymore. Now, on the flip side, you know, the average person earning the median wage can, you know, can go and buy bookcases at IKEA and have a good life with them, have a better life with them, right? But what we've given up in terms of quality, we've gained back in terms of maybe inching up the median quality of life in that sense. But still, there's a market for high-quality furniture, right? Right.
今天，人们无法买到高质量的家具，当然绝不像一百年前那样能够买到了，对吧？原因很简单，因为已经没有人再制作那种高质量的家具了。现在，反过来看，你知道的，拿着中位工资的普通人可以去宜家购买书架，并以此过上美好的生活，过上更好的生活，对吧？但是，我们在质量上所放弃的，在某种程度上通过微调平均生活质量给赢了回来。不过，高档家具仍然有市场，对吧？确实如此。
It's now a high-end market. And I don't want to turn this into the couch episode, but just to say that. And so, you know, maybe, maybe this is the way that software engineering is going. Maybe these AI tools increase the ability of less experienced people to get what they need done with software. right? But also maybe they compress or sort of hyper extend the tail of our ability to actually write good quality software and a number of practitioners who are doing that in future. I don't know. It's just an interesting thought. Well, this is great, folks. We've entered what will we title this part two of this conversation? Because, I mean, let's, I want to hear from you more because the last time we spoke on this, if my memory serves correctly, was like August of
现在它成了一个高端市场。我不想把这变成沙发播客，但只想说明这一点。所以，也许，也许这就是软件工程的发展方向。也许这些人工智能工具提高了经验较少的人用软件完成他们所需工作的能力，对吧？但同时，它们也可能压缩或某种程度上过度延长了我们实际编写高质量软件的能力的尾部，以及未来从事这项工作的许多从业者的尾部。我不知道。这只是一个有趣的思考。好吧，各位，这太棒了。我们进入了——我们该如何给这场对话的第二部分命名？因为，我是说，我想听听你更多的想法，因为如果我们记忆没错的话，我们上次谈论这个话题是在
last year, which was not a full year ago. This is May, end of May, this June. But we'll say 10 months. And at the time, I recall, you were nonplussed about the tools. And I remember you anecdotally said, I think that you were using some kind of code review tool. And it basically, I can't remember if you were on GitHub or GitLab or some equivalent, but it basically broke the PRs because they were just, you know, putting so many comments
去年，也就是不到一整年前。现在是五月，五月底，马上六月了。但我们就算作10个月吧。当时我记得，你对这些工具不以为然。我记得你顺便提到过，我想你当时在使用某种代码审查工具。基本上，我记不清你当时是在GitHub、GitLab还是类似的平台上，但它基本上搞砸了PR，因为它们只是，你知道，留下了太多的评论
and nonsense. It was just creating more work. It wasn't helpful. What is the 10 months later? because in that past 10 months, we passed the December of 2025 where all the models had a big step up. And, you know, alongside that, you know, Claude Code, Claude Co-work, et cetera. A lot of things have changed in the last 10 months. What's the update?
和废话。这只是在增加更多的工作量。它一点也不帮忙。10个月后情况怎么样了？因为在过去的10个月里，我们迎来了2025年12月，当时所有的模型都迎来了重大飞跃。而且，伴随着这一点，你知道，还有Claude Code、Claude Co-work等等。在过去的10个月里，很多事情都发生了变化。有什么最新看法？
I mean, we've heard a little bit in the last 10 to 20 minutes. If you're going to push me to it. I push you to do nothing. We can talk about something else if you want. But I am very curious as a friend. So again, I don't really want to make an argument about AI's lack of ability, because I'm aware that it will get better. But I remain, mostly, finding myself unable to square my ethics with using these tools. Say more, is that from the, what it's doing to the code, what it's doing to the industry, or what it's doing to just the world and large?
我是说，我们在过去的10到20分钟里已经听到了一些。如果你非要逼我说的话。我可没有逼你做什么。如果你想的话我们可以聊点别的。但我作为朋友实在很好奇。所以再次重申，我并不是想去争论人工智能能力不足的问题，因为我知道它会变得更好。但我发现自己绝大多数情况下仍然无法将我的道德准则与使用这些工具结合起来。能多说点吗，这是因为这些工具对代码的影响、对行业的影响，还是对整个宏观世界的影响？
Or all of the above? All of the above, right? So, like I think I mentioned when we were talking some time before, like last CPP con, there were several talks about AI and there seemed to be more about in every conference. And in particular, several of the talks started out by saying, okay, I'm not going to address any non-technical concerns. We're just going to stick to the technicalities. And, you know, that's a very sort of privileged position to take. And I find myself unable to take that position. Man is a political animal, as Aristotle said.
还是以上皆有？以上皆有，对吧？所以，就像我之前提到的，比如上一届CPP con上，有几场关于人工智能的演讲，而且似乎每个会议上关于这方面的演讲都更多了。特别是，有几场演讲一开场就说，好吧，我不会去谈任何非技术性的担忧。我们只专注于技术细节。你知道，这是一种非常具有特权地位的表态。而我发现自己无法采取那种立场。正如亚里士多德所说，人是政治动物。
you cannot not, you know, inaction is a form of action. And I just sort of look around and I ask myself, is this doing the world any good? I see, and part of it, it's not even really AI. It's just this kind of extreme capitalism society we're now living in, where wealth is so concentrated that it is, you know, people and companies are now outside of the law. Like just ask yourself what effect AI is currently having on on the, for example, the free software slash open source world that that is the bedrock in many ways of of the technical society we enjoy today. Yeah. And, you know, while I am no fan of the particulars of copyright law, I recognize that copy left exists because of copyright. right and at least in the u.s the current position which seems to be clear if even if we don't agree with
你不可能不表态，你知道，不作为也是一种行为。我只是环顾四周，问问自己，这真的对世界有任何好处吗？我明白，部分原因甚至不是人工智能本身。而是我们现在生活的这种极端资本主义社会，财富高度集中，以至于，你知道，人们和公司现在都凌驾于法律之上了。只要想想人工智能目前对以下方面产生了什么影响，例如，自由软件/开源世界——它在许多方面是我们今天享受的技术社会的基石。是的。而且，虽然我不喜欢版权法的具体细节，但我承认左翼版权（copyleft）的存在正是因为版权的存在。对吧，至少在美国，目前的立场似乎很明确，即使我们不赞同
it so far is that if if a human didn't make it it can't be copyrighted and from the research i've done that that includes AI prompting prompting's not enough to say a human made it so you know i'm not a lawyer so i simply can't go any further than that but but it seems to me that a I generated code is uncopyrightable. And it's also, since it's so easy to copy once you can, once you see, once you see the behavior of a system, if you can ask your AI to regenerate it, that means trade secrets are also out the window. That means, you know, and basically, I don't know with an intellectual property, right?
它到目前为止的看法是，如果不是人类制作的，就不能获得版权。根据我做过的一些研究，这包括AI提示词（prompting），提示词并不足以说明这是人类制作的。所以，你知道，我不是律师，所以我根本无法深入探讨，但在我看来，人工智能生成的代码是无法获得版权的。而且，由于一旦你能看到一个系统的行为，它就很容易被复制——如果你可以让你的人工智能重新生成它，那就意味着商业机密也荡然无存了。这意味着，你知道，基本上，我不知道这算什么知识产权法，对吧？
I don't know. But what I do know is that probably every form of open source in the world, Every open endeavor has had to make a decision about where they stand on AI. And to my mind, the only currently defensible position is to simply not take any AI contributions. Do you actually know what most... I couldn't say. I couldn't say what most are doing. I listen to a lot of podcasts and I've heard people talk about it, but I don't actually know... So that is just talking about sort of the one form of the...
我不知道。但我所知道的是，世界上可能每一种形式的开源，每一项开放的努力，都不得不就它们对人工智能的立场做出决定。在我看来，目前唯一站得住脚的立场就是简单地不接受任何人工智能的贡献。你真的知道大多数...我不好说。我不好说大多数人都在做什么。我听了很多播客，也听过人们谈论它，但我其实并不清楚...所以这只是在讨论某种...
legal concerns. Of course, the other side is that, you know, to ask another question, a question which might make people feel uncomfortable, you know, the question that J.F. Bastion asked in a talk a couple of years ago, have you ever written code that killed someone unintentionally? And you know, I work on power management code inside the Intel CPU package. If my code fails, it could kill someone or contribute to it. When I was writing in games, I didn't have these concerns,
法律层面的担忧。当然，另一方面，你知道，去问另一个问题——一个可能会让人们感到不适的问题，也就是J.F.巴斯蒂安（J.F. Bastion）几年前在一次演讲中提出的问题：你曾经写过无意中害死人的代码吗？你知道，我在英特尔CPU封装内部从事电源管理代码的工作。如果我的代码失效，它可能会害死某人或对此负有责任。当我从事游戏开发时，我没有这些担忧，
pretty much by and large. When I was working in finance, I had more concerns because while it wouldn't kill someone, it could, you know, bankrupt them. Now I've moved further into being actually, in part, responsible for human life, it seems. And so I really do have a moral responsibility.
基本上大体上是这样。当我从事金融工作时，我有更多的担忧，因为虽然它不会害死人，但它可能会，你知道，让他们破产。现在我更进一步，实际上在某种程度上要对人类生命负责了。所以我的确承担着道德责任。
That is, I mean, I've mentioned when I talk to a few people that as much as people might be excited about AI coding, there's always going to be, you know, do you really want to be in a self-driving car where all the software was vibe-coded? Probably not. Probably you're going to want that code to be hardened and at a bare minimum, like, aggressively tested if you've got some AI system helping contribute like design stuff. Anyway, so that there are, if you're vibe coding your own personal link tree website, which I myself have done, you know, that's not going to hurt anybody. But all software is not like that. There is some software that lives inside of people on devices that are responsible literally for keeping people's hearts beating. It's kind of a cliche that, you know, engineers, software engineers, people who know how the sausages made, oftentimes are much more chary about,
也就是说，我跟一些人交流时曾提到过，尽管人们可能对AI编程感到兴奋，但总会有人——你想坐上一辆所有软件都是靠感觉乱调（vibe-coded）写出来的自动驾驶汽车吗？大概不想吧。大概你会希望这些代码经过加固，退一步讲，如果有某个AI系统协助贡献设计之类的内容，也要进行激进的测试。总之，如果你只是在用感觉乱调（vibe coding）写你自己的个人链接树网站，我自己也干过，你知道，那不会伤害任何人。但并非所有软件都是那样的。有些软件存在于人体内部的设备中，字面意义上负责维持人们的心跳。这算是个陈词滥调了，你知道，工程师、软件工程师、那些知道香肠是怎么做出来的人，往往对...
the devices in their homes you know like most of us probably wouldn't want to put an electronic lock on our front door for example oh yeah it's the analogy of like the CEO of Coke not letting his kids drink Coke because he knows what goes into it
他们家里的设备，你知道，比如我们大多数人可能不想在我们的前门上安装电子锁，举个例子。哦，对，这就好比可口可乐的CEO不让他的孩子们喝可乐，因为他知道里面放了什么东西一样。
people that design some kind of aviation software are like pretty fearful every time they get in a plane not I'm not saying that's a true story for folks to scare the people out there I'm just saying I've heard stories like that where they're like oh no I would never insert do something because
设计某种航空软件的人每次上飞机都相当害怕，我不是说这是一个吓唬大家的真实故事，我只是说我听说过这样的故事，他们会说，哦不，我绝不会去插入或做某事，因为
yeah they know how the software yeah it's kind of a cliche to the point of being a joke right almost but it has some truth to it yeah so yeah so the update is still not a big fan and also to unlike many develop or go ahead
是的，他们知道软件是怎么运作的。是的，这简直成了个老生常谈的笑话了，对吧？但它确实有一定道理。所以，是的，所以我的最新看法依然是：我仍然不是它的超级粉丝。而且，不像许多开发者，请继续
yes sorry you're right I didn't mean to interrupt but I was going to say something else like like it's undoubtedly true that AI is a useful tool in many areas one of the places I've seen it being very useful is in diagnostics, right? So finding problems in these systems that we build,
是的，抱歉，你说得对，我不是故意打断你的，但我想说点别的，比如，毫无疑问，人工智能在许多领域是一个有用的工具。我看到它非常有用地方之一就是在诊断方面，对吧？也就是在这些我们构建的系统中发现问题，
which are, because there are always problems in shipping systems, right? And sometimes they only show up in the fully baked system when it's very hard to trace them back to their source. And sometimes LLMs can help with those kind of diagnostics. They're quite good at that, it seems. Or at least, they can troll through a lot more possibilities a lot more quickly than a human.
这些系统由于发布的产品中总会存在问题（对吧？），有时它们只在完全成熟的系统中显现出来，而这时要追溯其根源非常困难。有时大语言模型（LLM）可以协助进行这类诊断。看来它们在这方面相当擅长。或者至少，与人类相比，它们能够更快地筛查出更多的可能性。
can decrease the time to root cause an issue. That's true. Like, that's valuable. But in many cases, we fail to close the loop, right? Given this very powerful new tool, there is a risk that we say, oh, now we have a new tool for diagnosing these things. Great. We'll do that. What we should be saying is how can we prevent those issues from occurring again, right? And it's sort of a It's sort of a Conway's Law thing as well, right? Which is that, for the listeners, the technical structure of an artifact produced by an organization mirrors the communication structure of that organization. In other words, if you have two teams working on a piece of software, you'll get a piece of software with two very well-defined parts with an interface between them, for example. And so the people who find the issues are on a team, a different team from the people who wrote the code.
能够缩短找到问题根源的时间。确实如此。这很有价值。但在许多情况下，我们未能形成闭环，对吧？鉴于这个非常强大的新工具，我们可能会面临这样一种风险：我们说，哦，现在我们有了诊断这些问题的新工具。太棒了。我们就这么做吧。而我们其实应该说的是，我们该如何防止这些问题再次发生，对吧？这有点像康威定律（Conway's Law），对吧？也就是说，对于听众来说，一个组织所产出的工件的技术结构，镜像了该组织的沟通结构。换句话说，如果你有两个团队在开发同一软件，你会得到一个包含两个定义明确部分并通过接口连接的软件，例如。因此，发现问题的人所在的团队，与编写代码的人所在的团队是不同的。
code, right? And so what we need to do is close that loop to say not just, okay, finding issues might be easier now because we can diagnose them more easily, but also actually how do we work backwards? How do we prevent those from happening in future? This is just, an AI is just the latest tool in this line, right? This is not, this problem is not even AI related. This is a problem of like fundamentally doing good engineering. Once more, Connor will cut that piece out.
代码，对吧？所以我们需要做的是形成闭环，不仅要说“好吧，现在发现问题可能更容易了，因为我们可以更轻松地进行诊断”，还要切实思考我们如何进行逆向推导？如何在未来防止这些情况的发生？这不过是，人工智能只是这一脉相承的最新工具罢了，对吧？这甚至不是一个与人工智能相关的问题，这是一个关于如何从根本上做好工程设计的问题。再次强调，康纳会把这段剪掉的。
Yeah, Connor just thought for like 15 seconds. I mean, yeah, it's food for thought. I mean, maybe the takeaway is that the fundamental engineering problems haven't changed, right? That is definitely one takeaway from this conversation, I think. Yeah. I mean, I completely agree with that. And I guess some of the things, I don't know, am I too optimistic? But when I hear, you know, closing the loop, my thought is like, so you build a diagram,
是的，康纳刚刚思考了大概15秒。我的意思是，这确实挺引人深思的。我的核心收获或许在于，基础的工程学问题其实并没有改变，对吧？这绝对是这次对话中我的一点体会，我觉得。是的。我是说，我完全同意这一点。我想有些事情，我不知道，我是不是太乐观了？但当我听到什么闭环之类的说法时，我的想法是，你构建了一个图表，
diagnostic tool for catching stuff, you know, perfect. Put that in like the CICD pipeline. And then ideally, nothing gets pushed out to production with that set of bugs. Sure. You could do that. But you're potentially, and that would be good. But it wouldn't be the best option, right, in the long run. Because now you're putting more burden on your CICD pipeline.
用来捕获各种问题的诊断工具，你知道，这很完美。把它放进类似CI/CD的流水线里。然后理想情况下，带着这组Bug的代码就不会被发布到生产环境中去。当然。你完全可以这样做。而且这可能会很不错。但从长远来看，它可能并不是最佳选择，对吧？因为现在你给CI/CD流水线增加了更多负担。
maybe and and and you know CICD times are always at a premium we always want CICD to run faster right but now you're you're burdening that you're you're it's the same thing as like testing at the wrong level right and this this is another thing you know unrelated to even AI right this is something I see across across multiple industries where where a given company will have a particular strength in a certain area of testing like maybe you're you know your your quality validation engineers are really, really good, and they catch tons of things, right? But then being really, really good can mean that the engineers writing the software end up relying on them to find issues, which actually should be caught in a unit test
也许而且你知道CI/CD的运行时间总是非常宝贵的，我们总是希望CI/CD跑得更快，对吧？但现在你正在给它增加负担，这其实就和在错误层级进行测试是同一回事，对吧？而这又是另一回事，甚至和人工智能无关，这是我在多个不同行业中都能看到的一种现象：某个公司会在特定的测试领域拥有某种优势，比如说，你们的质量验证工程师真的非常非常厉害，他们能抓到成吨的问题，对吧？但他们太厉害了，这就意味着编写软件的工程师最终会依赖他们来发现本该在单元测试中就被捕获的问题，
before it ever leaves the engineer's machine, right, at a much lower cost in terms of time and energy, right? The analogy here actually, I just popped into my head, which probably should have popped in sooner is my wife's, one of my wife's many specialties, but her primary specialty is public health and preventive medicine. And there's two different types of medical, I don't know what you call them, schools of thought. And the primary one that we live in today is a, it's reactive. Yeah, reactive, yeah.
在代码离开工程师的电脑之前就解决掉，对吧？这样在时间和精力方面的成本要低得多。其实我脑子里刚刚蹦出了一个类比，可能应该早点想到的，那就是我太太的专业领域之一——或者说她的主要专业领域——是公共卫生和预防医学。医学界其实有两种不同类型的，我不知道该怎么称呼它们，医学思想流派。我们今天身处其中的主流流派是，它是反应式的。对，就是反应式的，对。
Which to translate means you have something wrong. You go to your doctor and then you get prescribed, you know, pills or some kind of remedy thing versus a preventive based medicine system where. you proactively are doing things like trying to exercise and eat healthy and, you know, a bunch of things that if globally or even nationally people were to do this, you would end up with orders of magnitude less illnesses down the road. And it's actually like the better, the more cost efficient. Like if you were to invest more in preventative stuff and made sure that people were just
用大白话解释就是，你身体出了问题，去找医生，然后医生给你开药，也就是各种药丸或者某种治疗方法；这与基于预防的医学系统形成了对比，在预防医学系统中，你积极主动地去做一些事情，比如尝试锻炼身体、健康饮食，还有很多事情——如果全球甚至全国的人们都能这样做，你在未来就会遇到少几个数量级的疾病。而且这其实是更好、更具成本效益的方式。如果你能在预防方面投入更多，确保人们保持
healthier, it would be much, much cheaper than the money that gets spent on dealing with disease and illness, but it is from like a political point of view. And it's also too, it's not the status quo. So that's a whole other issue. It's very hard to get, you know, institutions to spend money to switch a system from like a reactive to a preventive. Anyways, that's what you're arguing here, which is a great analogy is that, sure, throw some check that you design to catch this stuff.
健康，那可比花钱去治疗疾病要便宜得多得多。但从政治角度来看，而且这也是现状之外的改变，所以这完全是另一回事。要让机构花钱把系统从反应式转变为预防式是非常困难的。总之，这正是你在这里要讨论的观点，这是一个很棒的类比：当然，你可以抛出一些自己设计的检查机制来捕获这些问题，
But that's just solving the symptom. It's not sort of the problem of like, yes. You know, how about we just train software engineers to have better, you know, software design skills, insert, all the other things that software engineers should be better at. And then we won't need to rely on the CICD systems with, you know, 30 different checks for this thing and that thing because, I mean, it's still good to have those at the end of the day, but you're going to end up having to, you're going to end up with CICD passing a lot more. And so the whatever, compute or the spend that you have to spend on the CICD compute will go down.
但这只是在解决症状。它并没有真正解决问题，比如，为什么我们不直接培训软件工程师让他们具备更好的软件设计技能，以及所有软件工程师本该更擅长的其他技能呢？这样我们就不需要依赖那些带有30种不同检查项的CI/CD系统了，因为，我的意思是，归根结底这些检查保留着也无妨，但你最终会发现CI/CD通过率会高得多。因此，你在CI/CD计算资源上花费的成本或算力就会下降。
And you're relying on that stuff less because you've got better engineers. To bring it back to the engineering realm, again from the medical realm a little bit, it's, you know, AI makes things easy, but I'm not interested in easy. I'm interested in simple, right? Same as Rich Hickey is. And AI is really, really good at making things easy. It makes a lot of things much easier. But it's not really good at making things simple yet. Yeah. I mean, I have to say, I do find it hard, like, in my brain to square this anecdotal. with like a few things that I've done which admittedly I've never looked at the code so it is probably not great it's probably bad there's probably a ton of technical debt not to speak of cognitive debt I don't understand what it's doing in the first place so like what is that 100% cognitive debt maybe and but the thing is is like I never have things that you've built for yourself sorry I hope these are things you've just built as one off for yourself and not things that you are shipping professionally well no definitely not shipping professional
由于你拥有了更优秀的工程师，你对那些东西的依赖就会减少。再把话题拉回工程领域，稍微结合一下刚才医学领域的说法，你知道，人工智能把事情变简单了，但我对“简单”不感兴趣，我对“纯粹/不杂乱”感兴趣，对吧？就像里奇·希基（Rich Hickey）一样。人工智能确实非常非常擅长把事情变得容易。它让很多事情变得容易多了。但它还不是很擅长把事情变得真正纯粹。是的。我是说，我必须承认，我确实觉得很难在脑子里把这种轶事跟我做过的一些事情协调起来，虽然承认我从来没看过代码，所以它可能不太好，可能很糟糕，可能存在大量的技术债，更不用说认知债了，我一开始甚至根本不明白它在干什么，所以这大概是100%的认知 debt 吧？而且问题在于，我从来没有遇到过那种情况——等等，你构建的这些东西都是你自己用的吗？抱歉，我希望这些只是你为自己随手写的一次性小工具，而不是那种你要拿去进行专业交付的东西。哦，不，绝对不是用于专业交付的。
But I mean, the one example that I'm thinking about in my head is my array box website, which is like a REPL for different array languages. As of the day, it's had 2,000 plus unique visitors and 32,000 code evaluations, the little array box server that's sitting on my wife's old laptop downstairs. I think it's been running for, I don't know, 1,400 hours straight without crashing. And like, this, I never had the skill set nor the time to build. but it's something I've always wanted, and it has been, like, it's, it's been amazing. I always wanted something like this. It brings me so much joy to use it. Is it probably failing all of the metrics and things we just talked about? Absolutely. Well, but it's horses for courses, right. So you're right. It's solved your problem.
但我的意思是，我脑子里想到的一个例子就是我的array box网站，它是一个针对各种数组语言的REPL（交互式解释器）。截至今天，它已经有了2000多名独立访客和32000次代码评估，那个小小的array box服务器就放在楼下我太太的旧笔记本电脑上。我想它大概已经连续运行了1400个小时没有崩溃。而且，我以前既没有这个技能也没有时间去构建它，但这是我一直想要的东西，而且它真的，真的太棒了。我一直想要这样的东西。使用它给我带来了巨大的快乐。它可能不符合我们刚才讨论的所有指标和标准吗？绝对是的。嗯，不过适合的场景用适合的工具，对吧。所以你说得对。它确实解决了你的问题。
And you are benefiting from the fact that your problem is a small problem with a small number of people. Like, like, it's your solution currently fits your problem space. But if your problem space changes, right? And this is what engineering is about, right? If you suddenly got a million daily visitors, your box would fall over. If you suddenly got attention from hackers and people trying to penetrate the system, you would be well advised to take it down, right? I don't think these are controversial statements.
而且你正在享受这样一个事实：你的问题是一个小问题，只涉及少量的用户。比如，你的解决方案目前刚好契合你的问题空间。但是如果你的问题空间变了呢？这就是工程学的意义所在，对吧？如果你突然迎来了每天一百万的访客，你的那个“盒子”就会崩溃。如果你突然引起了黑客和那些试图渗透系统的恶意人员的注意，你最好赶紧把它下线，对吧？我不认为这些是有争议的观点。
It's a different problem. Well, I mean, I was, I had. a few people trying to hack it at the beginning. Like, I mean, let's try and make the box fall over, folks. I mean, most of the stuff is server side, so there's nothing. But also, like, there's not great value in penetrating it, right? You don't get access to, you know, Bitcoin wallets.
这是个不同的问题。好吧，我的意思是，在一开始确实有几个人试图黑它。我是说，大家来试试看能不能让这个盒子崩溃吧，各位。我的意思是，大多数东西都是在服务端处理的，所以没什么好担管的。而且，渗透它也没有什么巨大的价值，对吧？你又拿不到什么比特币钱包。
You don't get access to credentials, pretty much. You get to take over one small PC of an individual, big whoop, right? it's not a high value target which again is like I'm saying you're living in a problem space that is a different problem space right but engineering if we if we are engineers we're trying to build these systems that are robust reliable
基本上你也拿不到凭据。你顶多能接管某个人的一台小PC，大不了什么嘛，对吧？它不是一个高价值目标，这也正是我刚才所说的：你生活在一个不同的问题空间里，但工程学，如果我们真的是工程师，我们试图构建的是那些能够保持稳健、可靠的系统。
sure they sit in the problem space but the problem space is much expanded right the problem space is often global and it does include all these things and so it behooves us to do actual engineering now the other things thing to touch on, I forget what you said. You said it in a minute ago, but it made me think like something else Michael said in a recent talk.
它们当然存在于问题空间中，但问题空间要大得多，对吧？问题空间通常是全球性的，并且包含了所有这些因素，因此我们有必要进行真正的工程实践。另外还有一点要提一下，我忘了你刚才说什么了。你几分钟前说过，但它让我想起了迈克尔在最近的一次演讲中提到的另一件事。
If you as a team, as an engineering team, do these good engineering things. If you make things simple, if you are able to, you know, not have cognitive debt, not have intent debt, if you're able to become a trusted part of your organization and, and fulfill that structural quality and fulfill that functional quality and the process quality, such that you can reliably ship good quality software. How that shows up is that you don't do heroics, right? You don't have sudden fires to fight because by doing the engineering, you have avoided those things.
如果你作为一个团队，作为一个工程团队，做了这些正确的工程实践。如果你把事情做得纯粹简单，如果你能够不背负认知债、不背负意图债，如果你能够成为组织中值得信赖的一部分，并履行好结构性质量、功能质量以及过程质量，从而能够可靠地交付高质量的软件。这所带来的表现就是，你不需要搞英雄主义，对吧？你不会突然面临到处救火的窘境，因为通过认认真真的工程实践，你已经避免了这些事情。
And so what that looks like from the outside is, well, your team is doing things that are easy. Our team that has all these problems, we do much more complicated things than you do, right? This is how people see you. If in fact you do good engineering and avoid the problems, right? You don't, you don't, you almost never get the benefit because, you know, other people who are finding their engineering hard because it is complex, not simple. What they are doing is complex and what you are doing is going for simple, right?
所以从外部来看，这给人的感觉是，你们团队在做一些很容易的事。而我们这个团队有着各种各样的问题，我们做的事情比你们复杂得多，对吧？如果你们实际上做了良好的工程实践并避免了问题，人们就是这样看你们的，对吧？你几乎永远无法获得这种好处，因为，你知道，其他那些因为工程学很复杂（而不是纯粹简单）而觉得举步维艰的人，他们所做的事情是复杂的，而你们所追求的是纯粹简单，对吧？
What they are doing may be easy, right? Because easy is a relative term. It's what they know how to do. but you know when you see a team when your team is struggling with complexity and and you are not recognizing that and you see a team doing things simple then the natural the natural thing to think is well they they have it easy right they never have to fight fires they know but but that's the wrong thing to take away the thing takeaway is wow you know they never have to fight fires what are they doing to achieve that yeah i guess i guess really the maybe that's why maybe that's why
他们所做的事情可能觉得很简单，对吧？因为“容易”是一个相对的概念。那是他们知道该怎么做的事。但是你知道，当你看到一个团队——当你的团队在复杂性中苦苦挣扎而你却没有意识到这一点，然后你看到另一个团队把事情做得很简单时，你的第一直觉自然会认为，好吧，他们过得很轻松，对吧？他们从来不需要救火。你知道，但这种想法是完全错误的。真正的体会应该是：哇，他们居然从来不需要救火，他们到底做了什么才达到这种效果？是的，我想，我想也许这就是为什么，也许这就是为什么
I've been so excited about these tools is because I had a bunch of personal projects. Well, I always wanted to do. They've been very good for that. It sounds like. Yeah, and I was able to build those. But yeah, I guess what would I, what would my take be if I worked at like a medical devices company? Probably I would be a lot less excited because even if it was helping me to do certain tasks faster, there's no way I'd be vibe coding, you know, the next 2.0 device that is going to go, you know. We should interview someone who worked.
我对这些工具如此兴奋的原因，是因为我有一堆个人项目。嗯，我一直想做那些。它们在这方面非常管用，听起来是这样。是的，我能够把它们造出来。但是，是的，我想如果我在一家医疗设备公司工作，我的看法会是什么呢？可能我会兴奋得多减少，因为即使它能帮我更快地完成某些任务，我也绝不可能用“Vibe Coding”（氛围编程）的方式去开发下一款即将投入使用的2.0版本设备。我们应该去采访一个在……工作的人。
at medical devices company and ask them perhaps. Yeah, or it doesn't necessarily need to be medical devices, but, and I mean, I know someone from my local meetup, I know some from my local meetup who works in medical devices, and I think she's using AI in some way. Perfect. I mean, well, perfect. Perfect if they want to come on. But yeah, maybe next time, because, yeah, even for, I think a lot of the stuff people are
医疗设备公司工作的人，也许可以问问他们。是的，或者这不一定非得是医疗设备，不过，我的意思是，我认识我本地聚会活动里的某个人，我认识本地聚会里有人从事医疗设备工作，我想她正在以某种方式使用人工智能。完美。我的意思是，这很完美。如果他们愿意来做客那就完美了。不过，也许下次吧，因为，是的，即使对于……我认为很多人
excited at Nvidia about using these forms. Or it's also not like, what do you call like critical software, you know, that like lives are dependent on? Infrastructural engineering. I don't know. Yeah. I don't know what you call it. I'm not to say that GPUs are not used in that kind of, yeah, infrastructural software.
在英伟达，人们对使用这些形式感到兴奋。或者这也并非什么……你把它叫什么来着，关键软件？你知道的，就是那种人命关天的软件？基础设施工程。我不知道。是的。我不知道这该叫什么。我并不是说GPU没有用在那种基础设施软件里。
But I think a lot of the things are kernels that are used for machine learning and AI stuff, which at the end of the day, maybe, you know, but. kind of feeding itself. Yeah, yeah, it's like this snake that's eating its own tail. And even if it's not, like, in the AI loop, you know, a lot of the machine learning stuff, it's for, like, you know, the classic example that was used on the team that I used to work for was like, you know, recommendation engines for like, you know, Netflix showing you what you might like next.
但我认为很多东西都是用于机器学习和人工智能的内核，到头来，也许，你知道的……这有点像在自我吞噬。是的，是的，就像一条吞食自己尾巴的蛇。而且即使它不在人工智能的循环之内，你知道，很多机器学习的东西，都是为了，比如，你知道的，我在过去工作的团队里经常使用的经典例子就是推荐引擎，比如网吧或Netflix向你展示你接下来可能会喜欢什么。
And, like, that sounds like, oh, why is that that important? Well, you know, if you have a really good, like, TikTok's recommendation engine leads to people being on the app, like, way more. Which, you know, setting aside whether that's good for. for society or not, is good for the company. Probably not. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion
而且，这听起来像是，哦，为什么这很重要呢？好吧，你知道，如果你有一个非常好的推荐引擎，比如TikTok的推荐引擎会让人在App上停留更长时间。这（抛开这对社会是好是坏不谈）对公司来说是件好事。可能对社会不是好事。请务必查看本集节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 网站上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论区的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下你的想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家过愉快的一天。我是反大括号（anti-brace）。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。